à Cheverny quelques kilomètres au sud de
Blois Valérie Giraudeau à l'île sa
passion des chevaux à celle de sa région
natale
bonjour
aujourd'hui elle emmène cette
influenceuse franco-américaine et sa
maman emballage
secret avec les chevaux premier secret
révélé en premier lieu nous allons
traverser les vignes de Cheverny ce que
savoure les soloniaux à l'apéritif à
Cheverny plusieurs hectares de vignes
sont cultivés en bio le vin est
d'appellation d'origine contrôlée
et comme souvent en Sologne il n'est pas
rare de croiser en pleine forêt un
château vieux de 600 ans voici le
château de Troussay qui est un château
Renaissance qui est le plus petit des
châteaux de la Loire qui se visitent je
trouve magnifique en fait c'est une
bonne taille pour
quelqu'un comme moi
[Rires]
pour satisfaire tous les visiteurs
rendez-vous à quelques pas d'ici là où
trône le château de Cheverny
sa façade de Crêts blanches sa symétrie
quasi parfaite attire quelques amateurs
de photographie et ont même inspiré un
certain Hergé pour créer le célèbre
château de Moulinsart je sais pas si
vous rappelez
et tout le monde tombe Haddock Nestor
tous les albums donc en fait on vient
ici principalement parce qu'on a lu
Tintin et que ces moulins ça en
pèlerinage pour certains pour d'autres
une découverte du mobilier ancien comme
cette tapisserie à l'époque tissée de
fil d'argent
bouquet final de la visite ce parterre
de tulipe 1/2 millions de bulles qui
viennent à peine d'éclore cette semaine